signer j'ai très envie de s'emmerder
alors maintenant c'est votre commentaire
je envie d'entendre d'abord en tant qu
ancien professeur de français jamais
vous n'auriez d'une chose comme ça
le terme voulez vous me prenez un petit
peu de co bon sens nous en sommes à une
semaine de commentaires jacques sur
cette question donc j'ai décidé de ne
plus commenter les commentaires comme ça
ça me permet je m'adresse à la
professeure de monde tirait bon je fais
du diable et qui avait aussi un langage
fleuri il ya eu
je pense que je regarde toujours ce
qu'il ya derrière cette phrase est
derrière cette phrase c'est la situation
actuelle à l'hôpital alors on va revenir
là dessus et jacques legros
hilare mais je le dis donc je fais pas
de politique je vais pas vous dire
franchement vont taper à gauche on tape
à droite on tape au milieu on tape
partout on t'a pas de jus sur le trouve
beaucoup
et c'est vrai que brigitte macron je la
connais je la connais un peu le bout et
c'est vraiment ne douceur non mais je
vous aime c'est j'ai rarement vu
quelqu'un d'aussi gentil c'est un amour
elle rentre pas du tout dans les trous
de politique tout ça jamais parle jamais
de ça mais c'est un amour voilà je vous
le dis ma mère aussi eu la chance de la
rencontrer un jour ce qu'elle est allée
elle a rencontré dans la rue lui ai dit
voilà et c'était vraiment aller toujours
très ouverts très sympathique très
gentil c'est vrai que là je me dis
apparemment mine de rien elle n'a même
pas check et les questions avant de
normalement
s'attendait à voir quelqu'un de peu de
pauline courtois
vous dites qui n'étaient que rosneft et
cornet c'est de s'en prendre au
président et certains d'ailleurs comme à
l'époque sa présidence la composeront
perdu leur place y avait une femme
charmante qui en ait qui ne parlent
jamais de politique qui venait pour les
pièces jaunes ya aucun courage et je
vous jure des courses politique je vous
jure il a dit aux gens qui nous
regardent c'est vraiment me suis jamais
vu gerald à un cadeau si gentil très
renommé cwick aucune éducation et aucun
accord avec est ce que on aurait
reproché sur ma jacques legros de ne pas
lui poser des questions parce qu'il
avait sur son plateau en plus comme
c'est une interview qui a été enregistré
si on aurait dit connivence les
questions oui elle ne parle jamais de
police
je suis désolé il a fait son boulot elle
a très bien répondu et justement alors
soir grandi parce qu'elle répond à
toutes les questions y compris les
rumeurs sans rial qui appuyé à voir sur
le net etc et donc il l'a fait il a fait
son travail signale en mourir à
une autre question d'incroyable elle est
revenue sur les rumeurs comme quoi elle
serait née homme vous avez vu c'est un
as mais là c'est odieux odieux montre la
première dame au chemin c'est vrai que
c'est vrai on a très peu sur twitter ça
marche oui regardez bien ce que me
demander son âge jeune femme se fait pas
ce qu'il a fait c'est pire convaincant
de cyber-harcèlement hausse et dont vous
même est régulièrement victime pardonnez
moi de revenir dessus d'un exemple cette
théorie conspirationniste contre
laquelle vous pensez porter plainte je
crois qu'ils affirment que vous êtes mes
hommes qu'est ce que vous pouvez
répondre à cela là bien évidemment c'est
un mensonge donc confirmer que votre
propos vous allez porter plainte c'est
bien sûr oui on est en train alors c'est
un petit peu long parce que il faut les
captures d'écran oui il faut
l'intégralité des propos les propos
rapportés donc en ce qui me concerne
c'est un petit peu le look alors oui moi
je suis extrêmement choqué par ce que
tf1 qui est réputé quand même pour ses
interviews de complaisance a voulu se
entre guillemets se payer brigitte
macron vous masser la maîtrise ont voulu
se donner une sorte de parangon de vertu
et enfin si jamais retrouvé leur à
définir mais les risques généraux et
votre tactique c'est de couper la parole
aux gens
surtout moi
ils ont voulu parce que c'est brigitte
macron montré qu'ils étaient redevenus
indépendants etc le procédé scandaleux
et les questions sont absolument indigne
le gros 8 même c'est que ce sont des
questions sol et il les pose sur digne
qui aurait le premier sur ce plateau à
dire complot connivence très dépréciée /
marketing et là tu viens devant valérie
tu ne vends pas d'une première dame si
c'est un homme
gère a dit mme maillet oui après on aura
daniel commence à réfléchir à ce qu'ils
donnent tout ce qu'ils appellent te
regarde cette année parce que je suis à
200% d'accord avec valérie je la trouve
courageux au hasard la trouve courageuse
la trop exceptionnel je la trouve libre
est en fait c enregistrés mais il avait
quand même les grandes thématiques
qu'ils avaient quand même les grands
axes moi je pense qu elle elle veut
qu'on lui pose c'est quel avion parce
que justement elle veut montrer qu'elle
a de la poigne voilà qu'elle n'est pas
juste une sorte de femmes prétexte elle
n'est pas le ventre et la ventriloque de
emmanuel macron et je pense que
justement c'est très fort et c'est
vraiment très bien joué de sa part
raymond non c'est surfait sur un buzz ça
tu te demande tu demande pas la première
dame de france qui vient pour les pièces
jaunes qu'est ce qui est du troll et
raymond tu vois bien que tout est sous
contrôle les enfants c'est l'exploit de
ce qu'il a dit votre marée sur emmerder
quand on rate son mari en face de toi
mais comme le fait d'avoir un bonhomme
comme la devanture d'une médaille il a
perdu de set haas pour sa suite il avoir
des couilles pas ça je dis bien une
femme qui met en valeur alors qu'ici
première dame de france elle aura déjà
vu quelqu'un première dame de france il
arrive vous êtes un homme alors non je
suis pas un homme donc j'étais justifier
comme un interrogatoire a demandé
désolé ils ont donné la preuve tous les
deux qu'on peut lui poser de bonnes
questions de la bonne façon et avoir des
réponses également moi j'ai trouvé mais
que c'était parfait de bout en bout et
je suis prêt à parier un week-end chez
moi que vous auriez été les premiers à
râler s'il avait pas
qui c'est qui a envie d'aller chez days
les tabous dont ils en pensent quoi
qu'on trouve du coup
les désaccords mais 81 des hommes sont
ulcérés c'est bizarre sur le toit
la série est ce que je suis non mais
évidemment il pose d hypothéquer son
coup tout le monde se pose est allé
poser ce serait une faute
professionnelle pour une vie d'amy
évidemment mais gilles tu dis n'importe
quoi tant que tu te reposes vraiment
cette question c'est est-ce que c'est
toi la toile et la classe américaine
arrête arrêté connais vraiment pas
d'écrire sur toi t'es pas journaliste
donc tu ne connais pas ce métier donc
faire voler
[Musique]
l'élection
[Applaudissements]
thyssenkrupp a alors adressé choi ils
posent des questions que tout le monde
se pointe évidemment que c'est évident
que c'est préparer évident que c'est
cadré et j'étudie de plus n'importe quoi
comme d'habitude quand cfa tu tape
dessus pas la queue basse est toujours
blanc ou noir avec toi voilà c'est tout
ça que la vie c'est un livre quand je
pose mes écrits respecter quand vous
anime une émission il ya 20 ans
toujours
jeune et gilles verdez du tout un jeu se
joue telle nouvelle on ne vient pas non
plus d'ailleurs
on s'affaire chez toi aussi
deux secondes à faire vibrer toutefois
que ça bouge ça aux
troubles dans la bouche et
il est décalé donc c'est énervant pour
ta gueule
[Musique]
il a dit un truc et des chocolats
l'instant il a dit on dispose des
questions tout le monde se pose je pense
vraiment et c'est long c'est très grave
que toute la france se demande des
premières dames jugement quand ça fait
autant c 'est pas de petit résultats de
façon grossière a comme tous ces
apprentis baptisé ouaga fonctionne hâtif
en fait je vois été
décidé
et raconte pas des mois
sa perche et de chanter limite
mes enfants ni d'avoir gardé sa veste
mais ce sont des bruits regardez
regardez ce qu'ils
vivent exactement regardez ben quoi ah
oui j'entends donner pas regarder ces
poux de pêche framboise écrasée ouais
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
tu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
as vu dans le jt tf1 on sert pas la
soupe aux halles a été excellent sur le
fond il ya posé toutes les questions et
sur la forme il a fait un truc qui
montre bien que le terme n'était pas
préparée c'est qu'il l'a relancé ça que
quand la réponse ne satisfaisait pas il
l'a poussée dans ses retranchements elle
a été prise de court elle a même reconnu
dans l'interview donc ça a donné un
échange très intéressant et au final les
sorties de gagner ceci est évidemment
merci alors mes chers es ce que vous
avez vu cette histoire incroyable aussi
donc je voulais vous pas avoir d'abord
le sondage sur elle j'ai passé à une
question at il été trop lents oui non
voyant la
hausse sur les bonnes questions là bas
que les gens ne sont pas éduqués
comme ça ils pharma qui te regarde je
vois pas qui te regarde moi je retire
voilà je retire j'ai retiré retire toi
dans l'énigme
les gens sont éduqués bien sûr que non
mais non pas comme ça une femme voilà ce
que je veux dire un certain âge
je le redis c'est que c'est un maire du
ministre qu'il adorerait et bien sûr et
les chats bah ouais vraiment mal je ne
connais pas la meilleure mais première
dame pour moi c'est la meilleure
première dame autant son mari peut être
clivant on peut l'adoré ou on peut le
détester en tant que président autant
elle est à la fois porteur qui m'a
choqué les mignonnes avait choisi
finalisions
marguerite si rim ses descendants sont
dans ce bouquin s'arrête